two very different men but united in
their compassion to break the stigma
around living with HIV Gareth Thomas a
former Welsh and British Lions rugby
captain is a legend of his sport two
months ago he made this incredibly
powerful announcement I'm living with
HIV now you have that information that
makes me extremely vulnerable but it
does not make me weak Prince Harry was
among the first to lend support to
Gareth HIV awareness a cause close to
his heart here seen getting publicly
tested for the virus the two men have
since continued to stand together in the
fight to educate people about HIV I did
something I'm really proud of but
there's more I want to do you know I
want to continue that message even
though that message was a lot bigger
than I ever thought it was gonna be here
we still need to get it out to more
people and we still need to get you know
more people I have to warn you might
come out because it's so cold out here
Gareth Thomas mitts he felt trapped and
ashamed after his diagnosis he says
Prince Harry a vocal campaigner about
mental health has been a huge help you
know he's been unbelievably unbelievably
supportive from day one yeah and it kind
of it kind of felt surreal but we had
something in common
because even though you know I'm from a
council estate in Bridgend and and he's
a royalty sometimes then barriers get
broken down when people are both
passionate about something like he
didn't have to phone me he didn't have
to text me to check him okay that's not
a royal duty he did it because he's a
human being who actually cares
they may seem worlds apart but Alfie and
Harry as they call each other are now
close friends sharing a love for rugby
and a strong desire to help others
Charlotte Lomas Sky News